What the heck?
Where'd the game go?
There it is.
Hello!
Oh no, my voice.
Sorry, I'm eating right now.
I'm eating a throat.
A cough drop.
Last word.
Hello!
I'm a little... I almost canceled today because I was like
oh my gosh my voice is I need a break can you combine mist
and minky without getting misty-y-ky what a way to start the
day good morning I had no signal at the con center for
yesterday's stream but it was my birthday I know it's your
birthday song I know happy
happy happy birthday hope your throat isn't too bad i think
it's just a little overworked at the moment just a little
just a little overworked i've been doing multiple recordings
um i had a collab collab maid cafe at assayoru friday and
saturday so two days in a row and when i talk to people i
just get so excited i'm just like I can't help but yell
because I'm so excited and I'm like so and then I had some
more recordings today and then I have some more recordings
tomorrow and then I have another convention next weekend but
after that after that I will finally have a break after that
finally I'll have a bit of a break so right now i'm i kind
of overbooked myself i'm in i'm a bit in overbooked hell at
the moment but that's okay that's okay sorry if you can hear
my sorry if you can hear my cough drop can't wait to see you
at the convention next week yeah see you there see you there
yeah
thank you for yesterday next week Oh, wait, Nixie, I also
forgot to tell you.
I don't know.
Wait, I don't know if Doki said anything yet.
But we're playing, well, she's playing Metal Gear this
coming week.
Finally.
I know it was supposed to happen while I was in Japan.
I'm so sorry.
What is happening?
I forgot to tell you that yesterday.
That's so cute seeing.
Doki cheering you on with the pen lights helping your voice
get dressed in.
Thank you.
By break, you better not mean stream every day.
well that no i mean like a break from events yeah doki doki
will be playing delta this week and i will be joining to um
to get very frustrated when she doesn't know the lore so
yeah yeah yeah yeah have fun stream video i'm gonna once
again noise.
Good night.
Sleep time.
I apologize, I was also in Japan.
And yeah, she told me yesterday.
Oh, okay.
Wow.
It's not like it's her stream or anything.
I can't believe she's telling you first.
I should have the honors.
It's about Metal Gear.
It's nice meeting you.
Weebsie!
Thanks for coming to see me yesterday.
I know she'll try and rage bait you.
Absolutely.
Because I know even more so that she'll try to because
because yesterday she was singing and I accidentally put a
beard over her face while she was singing like I was trying
to put it on me and for some reason it kept going on her.
I retweeted it It was accidental It really was But like It
looked so funny
Finally playing something more confusing than the games I
star And kept me waiting Huey Thanks for blessing us with
Santo Minto last night The cafe was so much fun Hope my MVP
art makes its way to your cafe Yeah!
Take care of us give it yeah they said that they will send
us everything so miss games have some of my favorite video
game music there's nothing at the moment there's no sound
it's so quiet um i picked the masterpiece edition um i
didn't i was like so you know when you like search a game on
steam why is it that when i search game hold on i'm going to
steam right now okay good i search mist and it comes up with
mist and then like four other random games that have nothing
to do with mist and so i didn't realize that this version
was on steam so i actually bought the i bought the 3d remake
but then at the same time i was just like oh i don't i i did
not do my due diligence And then I did not research which
port was the best or whatever.
So I was like, yeah, there's a VR version of this game.
That's, yeah, there's a mini golf.
I bought, no, I did not buy that one.
This is a game I remember watching my dad play.
Me too.
I know.
I was like, I'm gonna, I would play it.
And when I was a Wii Wisp, I would play it.
And then I don't think I...
made literally any progress at all which makes complete
sense because i was an idiot child so cool to meet you and
talk to you about all the idle stuff i got into because you
yeah
so much thank you thank you thank you thank you so yeah
we're gonna try and be the same now i am idiot adult uh
hopefully we can get through as much as possible without a
walkthrough.
We'll see.
We'll try.
Let's just start again.
Oh my god!
Mystery.
I realized the moment I fell into the fissure that the book
would not be destroyed as I had planned.
It continued falling into that starry expanse of which I had
only a fleeting cliff.
There's a story to this?
I've tried to speculate where it might have landed.
I must admit, however, such a conjecture is futile.
Still, questions about whose hands might one day hold my
misdemeanor are unsettling to me.
Straw, happy birthday!
I know my apprehensions might never be allayed.
And so I close.
Happy happy birthday!
Realizing that perhaps the ending has not yet been written.
Look.
Moust.
Open.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, what?
Missed.
Whoa.
That's all bored.
Oh, no.
Oh my gosh, point and click adventure.
Here we go, baby.
No.
We got the forest.
Ooh, we got something in the forest.
We've got a secret layer.
Oh.
We have a completely silent pot.
Just kidding.
This makes total sense.
Why can't I interact with it?
Interesting.
What's this?
Oh, what's this?
Settings, dimensional imager, topographical extrusion test,
water turbulent pool, marker switch diagram.
I can, okay, that's why it's on our water turbulent pool.
The reveal was...
Let's try 40.
Oh.
Wow, how inconvenient.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
It was too funny.
It was like the only time I've ever been funny to me.
Game was ahead of its time.
Oh, mountains!
Nice.
Let's see what else we got.
47.
Marker switch diagram.
So this is...
Oh, okay.
Whoa.
This is the marker switch.
Whatever that is.
Hey, girl, playing this with my daughter gave me a huge love
for pre-rendered graphics and is a large reason why I got
into FNAF.
Missed a FNAF pipeline.
Only you.
Otto, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Pep Member.
The Super Chat.
Thank you.
All right.
I'm clicking on everything.
Oh!
That's the switch!
The count of the dimes in the super chat says it all.
The number calls you from back in time.
No!
Let's see what's going on over here.
What's this?
Catherine.
I've left for you a message of utmost importance in our four
chamber beside the dock.
Remember the number of marker switches on this island into
the...
Oh, oh, enter the number of markers marker switches on this
island into the imager to retrieve the message.
Yours, Atrus.
Okay.
Atrus.
Okay, we have one.
We have two.
The dentist!
Do not.
Okay, for right now.
The dock near the where-where?
Okay, we have three.
None of them do anything yet.
The island can't be that big, right?
Oh my god, this is all so nostalgic.
What's that?
Okay, I'm...
Oh, I accidentally did something.
I wish Limbo of the Lost was easier to run.
Let me watch it go through that insanity, yeah?
Wait, how do I get out of here?
I accidentally did something.
QR code.
Oh.
I did something.
I was yesterday's tree, but I was busy getting older.
Set up fold!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Oh my god, it's a man!
Who are you?
Bring me a legend.
I
have seen you.
You don't let me get too much.
I can make a break for you.
Shh.
Huh?
What's he saying?
I am serious.
He's serious.
Or he's Siri.
He's Siri.
It's like the longest video ever.
My man's uploading his video on McDonald's Wi-Fi.
Come on!
Oh!
I feel like this is just one of those games where it's like
a thing will happen.
I don't want to go in there just quite yet.
Thing happened and you're like...
Oh, wait, did I just crawl through a... wait.
Oh, I think I'm waiting.
Oh, is this a hiding spot?
Wait, I can't like die or anything in this, can I?
Wait, this is a...
I saw you guys mentioning red pages, but then we have blue
page.
Oh god, not this again.
Serious?
Amigo!
Help me.
Blue pages.
What if all my streams were like this, you guys?
This is how I feel like my streams are gonna look like if I
stream out of a hotel.
What are these?
That's an off...
Ostrich?
Green.
Or red.
What the hell?
Maple Leaf.
Wait, that's another switch.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, there's already so many choices.
Which Teletubby's belly did they sacrifice to make these
books?
So I see that we are going to...
around doing things but why are we doing these things the
other png games you played had more of a setup for motive um
welcome to mist baby birds another one wait i've lost count
already
i feel like this game really scared me when i was a kid but
i don't remember power
power spaceship generator switches okay all right cool yeah
very interesting spaceship huh
spice oh we can swim right
call me call me dj squeakers Mist!
It says it up there!
There's another one.
Okay.
What else we got around here?
Something this way?
The spaceship!
Can I get electrocuted?
I guess we're trying to power up that bad boy.
Is that all of them?
So far?
Oh, we forgot to go back into the dentist office.
Well, I didn't forget it.
I just didn't want to.
What?
January 1st.
I don't know about Electro, but you're definitely cute.
Guys, you want to guess what today's drink of choices?
You want to guess?
Water.
Vodka.
Close.
I saw someone say it.
Today's drink of choices.
Everybody's saying Dr. Peppy.
Yeah, I can't have soda.
I can't have soda.
It's the drink of the day is...
Hot chocolate!
Oh my gosh, it's so cold.
And I probably should put on my sweater, but I'm still...
Stupid.
I want her to show off my tummy.
So...
How is that close to vodka?
Guilty pleasure.
Some of these beeping sounds.
Oh, here we go.
Let's go to my birthday.
October 1st.
Wow!
Square.
Ugh.
Let's see.
Let's go at it.
Wait, what is 20?
Wait, what?
What does this mean?
Is this the year?
Whoa!
Neat.
Was there anything else in here?
I thought it was a dentist office.
It's actually awesome.
Okay, what was this again?
Enter the number of marker switches on this island into the
imager to retrieve the message.
I'm guessing that place where we could...
So how many were there?
One.
Two.
What if there's like one hidden in these caves, you know?
Like I didn't go in here yet.
We'll go back, I guess.
Did you see the one by the clock tower?
I did, but I didn't count it because I lost track, so I
stopped counting.
Library!
Where is it?
Oh.
You can brute force the number pretty easily?
I believe that.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, clicking too fast.
Pretty sure, originally, you had to manually close the door
for the elevator to work.
Quality of life updates.
Woohoo!
Okay, interesting.
Okay, send us back home.
There's so many things going on.
So many things we can do.
Okay.
Wait, please let me out.
There we go.
Alright.
Let me go re- Okay, it was 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6?
Maybe?
6 of them?
Only 6 of them?
I see it.
Six of them.
I won't say...
Let's try...
The number above that.
Let's try the number above that.
Nothing.
I know your games.
Eight?
Brute force it.
Yeah, baby, we're brute forcing it.
Oh!
Catherine, my love.
I have to leave Woodley.
Something terrible has happened.
It's hard for me to believe.
Most of my books have been destroyed.
Catherine, it's one of our sons.
I suspect Akinah, but I shouldn't lead to conclusions.
I'll find him and Siris as well.
I should have known better than O'Leary.
left my library unchecked for so long well i've removed the
remaining undamaged books from the library and placed them
in the places of protection okay shouldn't have to use the
books until i return but if you've forgotten the access keys
remember the tower rotation oh and don't worry catherine
everything will be fine i'll see you shortly oh and erase
this message after reviewed it just to be safe.
Uh-oh.
Catherine, you had one job.
Catherine.
Also, the guy just left the note, like, in the middle of the
island.
Anybody could read it and figure it out, like I did.
What was it?
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
The something rotation?
What did he say?
The towel rotation?
He's like, be careful, Catherine.
this message don't let anybody know except you know snake
what's this abbo there's so many things here okay
what's this one even arrow
like a stone building in here.
Maybe I was crazy though.
So what was what did he say?
Tower rotation.
Maybe Catherine never saw it.
That's what I'm thinking.
There was this to the power.
Do you think it's also just trial and error to power the
spaceship?
And then what was here.
Oh, that was just another power thing.
Hmm.
I'll be having a good day.
Thank you.
Mystical greetings, Minto.
Hello.
Nothing needs to be trial and error in this game.
Trial and error is a choice.
Okay.
My urge to backseat.
Don't worry, your time will come.
Eventually.
I will I will ask for clues and hints.
Don't you worry.
Your sweet little head where you're like, I must tell her
what to do.
I must tell the VTuber where to go.
And how to progress.
Your time will come.
Flamingo.
Oh, okay.
There's also...
What else?
This thing over here.
Can I touch it?
Oh, no.
It has a mysterious aura.
By aura, just like a crazy soundtrack.
Every time I try to click on something, it, like, takes me
off the screen.
All of these sound effects are etched into my brain.
I wonder what these switches do.
Let's go back in here.
Open.
Maybe in here.
The library.
Open Sesame.
I haven't seen this game since I was a kid.
Your guess is as good as mine.
I don't know what I did.
I definitely played this as a kid.
But I have no idea, like, what I...
I did, you know what I mean?
I think I literally just clicked around in this specific
area and that was it.
Oh!
Oh, ho, ho!
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Is there anything that I can do with this?
No?
Hmm.
But now we have this one, which is...
Okay, I couldn't tell...
I still can't tell what it is.
It looks like there's something here, but it's so dark.
Yeah, a book ladder and a key ladder.
Okay, well, there was more stuff in here, but it is still
also mysterious.
Oh, tower rotation!
Wait, where was that?
That's right.
That was a thing.
Oh, I remember.
I remember.
We probably need to rotate the tower until we can...
Oh, thank you.
I completely forgot about that because it was so loud.
I'll turn it back down again.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, games, we won't even tell you what the puzzle is.
Walkabout mini golf has a level.
I know!
Based on mis-imagine having to solve the puzzles and score
under par.
Oh, heck no.
That turns a lot faster than I remember.
I didn't mean to turn it so much, but maybe a dramatic turn
is what we needed.
Tell me it made a difference.
Did it make no difference?
It made no difference.
You're looking at a different part of the wall.
Yeah, of course.
Alright, let's see.
We go back.
Oh, I think I let go.
Maybe like if I'm looking at this building, you know.
It sounds so scary.
Like it sounds too rickety.
To the library!
Almost at the finding the puzzle stage.
Hi Mint, hello!
Okay.
That still looks the same.
Oh, it still looks the same.
Is there something I'm missing?
Is this something I'm missing for the tower rotation?
Yes.
Oh, okay, okay.
The first puzzle is to find the puzzle.
Let's see.
Open!
Are any switches on?
No.
Time to flip some switch.
Oh, we'll start with the rocket switch.
All right.
Oh, right.
Flip them all, flip.
We'll do those three.
Yeah.
Wait.
Check this again.
I think
we need to flip more switches.
we need a...
Sorry if like my erratic clicking is...
But this, the one over at the clock tower...
We cannot get just yet.
The book and the key...
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, what was that?
Okay, interesting.
Oh, okay, okay.
I hope it rotated properly.
What is it?
What will it reveal?
Oh, nothing.
I'm too fast, too furious.
Have you checked the books on the bookshelf?
Yeah!
Oh, oh, what's that?
2.40.
2.2.
What?
That must be the stars?
Right?
Oh, gosh.
Am I going to need paper?
Uh-oh.
Okay, all right.
All right.
Hold on.
Let me...
Notepad.
So this is, um, the...
Um, what are those called?
Oh my god.
I just, my brain, my brain wants to call it a big clank.
2, 42, 2, 1.
Gear, yeah.
Oh, duh, is the metal gear.
Such a nice view of those metal gears.
My brain just wants to call it a big clank.
Why?
Don't worry about it.
Why could I not remember Metal Gear?
That's the worst thing ever!
Oh my god.
You know them big clanks?
I mean they do make a clanky noise, no?
Mado Misto.
Me dominto of the island of Misto, what is your wisdom of
the day?
Big then go Clank.
Okay.
For now, we'll get...
So this is the sunken ship.
For now, I'll just start writing these down.
And then once I leave, I'll observe the bookshelf.
My favorite franchise, Big Clank Solid.
Minto going to the big clank.
What did she do?
Good plan?
Okay, cool.
Glad you guys agree.
Yes, that's the sunken ship.
I like when you start doing things, the music starts
playing.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, okay.
October 11th, 1984, 10.04 a.m.
January 17, 12, 07, 5, 46 a.m.
You guys want to know what all these times are?
November 23rd, 979, 9791.
6, 57 p.m.
They're all times I met with your mother.
It's the streamings again.
Okay guys, see you in 9791!
Sick bird.
Thank you.
Alright, next one.
Wait, what about this guy though?
Sorry, I know it's a terrible sound.
So it's only the three?
Sappy Vinto is my dad.
Oh, I keep clicking out of the game for some reason.
Okay.
Alright guys, we're using our brains today.
This one is the spaceship.
Let's see what the spaceship has to offer for us.
It should be more than three.
Well, we don't have one unlocked at the moment.
So, oh my gosh.
Sometimes point and click is so frustrating.
Okay, there we go.
Just make it sure.
59 volts!
Okay.
That sounds like something we need to know to power that
baby.
Power that baby.
Are
you writing these down?
I am!
I sure am!
Yeah, 59.
These are the keys to the puzzles.
Uh, that's, that was it.
For now.
Maybe.
And let us observe this.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, hold on.
Okay, there's, there's four books.
five wait there's many books wait wait oh my gosh there's
many books okay
oh awesome i have called this age channel oh my god this is
so hard to read i have called this age channel wood and it
is a very different world though it is exactly how i
imagined it it is still amazing to see it with my own eyes
water covers this age as far as i could see thank you oh one
moment youtube told me i'm in your top 0.2 percent of
viewers thank you i can now declare with statistically
proven expertise thanks for all the fun streams is here
thank you Thank you, thank you.
Water covers this age as far as I can see, except for a
small rocky island.
Elsewhere there are only trees which grow directly out of
the water.
A myriad of thin wood passageways are built just above the
water and disappear into the forest.
I assume they were built some time ago for they appear aged.
I am eager to discover more about this land and its people.
but i have arrived here late and i must rest i was awakened
this morning by strange noises coming from a pathway
adjacent to one of to the one on which i had slept i saw a
group of monkey-like people heading in my direction not the
monkeys they had not seen me yet i did not feel threatened
by their presence their response to me was one that i would
have never expected after staring at me for a short time,
they fell to their knees and began to appear with sort of
ceremonial worship.
Minky.
Imagine just a little group of minkies.
I tried to speak to them, but they did not understand my
language.
Instead, they indicated through enthusiastic hand motions
that I was to follow them.
As we walked, I began to notice that the waters below were
changing colors.
Slowly, subtly, they, the world, well, oh, they would change
from deep blue to muddy orange.
orange to beautifully clear.
I was so intrigued by the water, I hardly noticed that we
had arrived at a ladder.
Climbing the ladder led to their village, which is about 10
meters above the water and can only be reached by rope
ladders that stretch from the lower paths to the village
level, approximately halfway up the grand trees.
There's a site called Miss Journey that has all the books
transcribed for easier reading.
Oh!
Thank you!
Right now, I'm okay though.
But thank you, thank you.
It is very interesting.
Oh my god, this is putting me to sleep.
It is very interesting watching these people carry out their
daily tasks.
Even after watching them for hours, I did not understand
exactly what they were doing.
How much is this?
So much text.
texto a lot this is very interesting yawn
i'll keep going i'll keep going ah as sunset they motioned
for me to follow them i followed the creatures to the
doorway of an enormous hut strangely once inside i found
that the hut appeared even larger than it had from the
outside that's the tortoise the walls were garnished with
bright metals and in the center of the hut sat the leader of
these people at least he appeared to be their leader for he
sat a meter off the floor in a thick throne guards
surrounded the strong creature who was dressed in many
exotic colorful fabrics next to the leader oh my gosh i
can't stop yari i can't stop still fighting the jet hag oh
my gosh because my the maid cafe ran until like 2 a.m ish
for me And then I took a shower afterwards.
And then I was still kind of like excited from the events.
I didn't sleep until 5 a.m.
I didn't sleep until 5.
So I didn't get much rest.
Um, next to the leader sat a very old human.
At least to some extent he appears human.
His hair, which was only on his face and head, was
completely gray.
almost white and hung very long around his frail body his
thin thin head what is a what is a thin head hung implied by
an almost grotesque neck that could not hold its head up to
look at me but what a surprise this creature could speak my
language shortly thereafter i was given a bed with some hand
motions that looked to be telling me to go to sleep i look
forward to learning more As I suspected, the ancient
creature is a human, but he is old beyond his own reckoning
and seems almost insane.
However, the tree dwellers almost revere him as a god.
They are treating me now in the same fashion, which makes me
feel very uncomfortable.
It is almost impossible to understand this old man.
So Vicky?
No, Vicky can remove her head.
She doesn't elongate her neck.
Different yokai.
his voice is feeble but wild he has adopted much of the
language of the tree dwellers he himself told me he had not
spoken our own tongue in ages I wonder do you guys think you
would forget English like
so doki yeah doki doki yeah I usually do in what time span I
don't know we don't know how long this guy guy's been here.
I wonder if I never spoke English, if I never used it, but
like, I think even if I, you know, if I learned another
language, like how he learned the tree dwellers language or
whatever, I still feel like I would think to myself in my
brain in English, you know what I mean.
So even if I didn't speak it, actually I also talked to
myself out loud.
I know some VTubers forgot their native language after
moving to another country.
That's kind of insane, actually.
How?
I feel like that's not possible.
VTubers have not been around long enough for that to happen
to someone, no?
I don't think that's true.
I don't know.
I think if you learn a second language, obviously it's
easier to forget that.
Hmm.
But yeah, I don't think, yeah.
Obviously, you can get rusty.
But completely forgetting?
I don't know about that.
I think it would have to be a really long time.
But yeah.
I don't know how long, though.
I feel like the human brain...
The brain should be able to remember the whole...
Anyway.
Uh, he attempted to explain to me the history of this place.
The following is my best translation of what he has told me.
Many years ago, the humans and tree dwellers lived together
in this place, which was then a vast island.
They interacted very little.
The humans dwelt on the ground, and the tree dwellers lived
high above the humans.
Occasionally, the island was disturbed by mysterious
rumblings, which happened randomly, some sort of tectonic or
volcanic action.
I suspect be sometimes slight sometimes heavy tremors would
only last a short time then they would stop allowing
everything to return to normal one day things changed the
rumblings began and grew quickly to unprecedented levels
soon it became apparent that the entire island was sinking
slowly into the ocean around them many of the humans died
that day but not before sacrificing themselves in order to
stop the sinking of the island the humans who lived through
this catastrophe moved into the trees where they gradually
died out.
Maybe because they were unequipped for such an environment.
But humans do not belong in the trees.
I am not sure.
This is the story the old man communicated to me.
Although many details are very unclear on my mind.
I am especially confused as to how the humans saved this
island from completely sinking.
Oh my gosh, what if it's all their bodies?
Their bodies are holding it up.
crazy
uh oh wait uh in fact i doubt the accuracy of that part of
the story the island must have stopped on its own yet the
old man believes in the truth of the story as if he had been
there i mean it sounds like he did no and the tree dwellers
worship him and apparently all humans as if he they were
heroes or gods today with an event which I will never
forget.
He began gripping my hands tightly, murmuring something
about rest and asleep.
He then said, we had expected you to come sooner.
Whoa!
These actions filled me with some sort of immediate dread.
With much effort, he stood to his feet.
I tried to help, but he pushed me away with more force than
I imagined his frail body contained.
The tree dwellers quietly surrounded him with very solemn
faces.
Then they kneeled before him.
He walked to each and placed his hand on their heads.
all the while he murmured words which i did not understand
finally he turned to me and smiled then he closed his eyes
and walked out the door and off of the narrow path high into
the trees wait what you and doki were my top two channels on
youtube this year thank you did you see the statue the
dragoons erected in your honor in minecraft is it the one of
me twerking because if so
What a monument it is.
The tree dwellers were silent.
They began a procession down the nearest rope ladder.
As I was descending, I saw several of them pick up the body.
He had fallen onto a lower level of walkway and carried it
away.
He was laying down at the dead end of the short pier-like
structure.
With the use of some potion, one of the tree creatures lit
the pier on fire, and I watched as the flames engulfed him.
As this strange funeral proceeded, the waters around the
pier changed to dull green.
Oh my gosh, he was green the whole time.
Green women.
Yeah!
This morning I woke, finding it hard to even believe the
previous evening's events.
a dull green for as far as i can see now for some reason the
water no longer shifts colors as i wander throughout the
passage of the pathways
oh my gosh it's also like the sound of the waves and
everything is put me to sleep the creatures watch me curious
to see what i will do next they're constantly offering me
strange objects of affection i even found food outside the
doorway to the room in which i had slept I hope to learn
their language soon so that I may learn more from them.
Oh, Catherine!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
This is like, this is the guy.
Oh, that, I think, did the message.
I have lived on this world for three months off and on, and
the tree dwellers have shown great hospitality.
I am even beginning to learn bits of their language.
I've decided to return home for an extended stay, with my
loving wife and my sons, and hopefully return with them.
However, I am sure Catherine will once again refuse.
I think this age would be a wonderful experience for them
all, and I at least look forward to how Sirius and Akanar
will react to its curious inhabitants.
Don't say, don't say, don't say, the ink is changing colors.
Pay attention to that.
Yeah, I figured it was probably important, right?
Ah!
Catherine is staying behind as expected.
My sons have returned with me and they enjoy this age very
much.
They get along very well with the tree dwellers and are
picking up their language surprisingly fast.
I have no doubt that it will not be too long until they can
speak with the tree dwellers much better than myself.
I am leaving tomorrow to check on...
O... O... Ozomoy... Ozomoyan age.
Sirius has suggested that I allow him and his father to
stay.
His father.
Oh, his brother.
My bad.
The script is hard to read.
Oh my god.
Wait, how much more?
Okay, just a couple more pages, guys.
I don't think I'll read every single book, but we'll see.
Just four more.
I have another cheesecake question.
Should I make regular Oreo or peanut butter Oreo?
Regular Oreo, regular Oreo, is my opinion.
Though the idea unsettles me, I know the boys are growing up
rapidly.
The hospitality of these creatures is such that I could
think of no better place to leave them alone for a short
while.
So I will consent to their request.
I warn the boys not to take advantage of the respect the
tree dwellers have for their ideas.
They seem to understand my warning, and I have faith they
will follow it.
thriving in ever, ever dunes.
I learned that Pran and her people are continuing to be
menaced by the...
Kuchi.
I still remember playing Miss when I was a kid.
They're cute for the severed cut!
By the what?
What does that say?
It's a real menace.
What does it say?
The...
chok-chok-chok-chok-chok-chok-chok.
A fear for their survival and plan on returning to her
shortly after checking on Sirus and Akanar here.
See Everdune's Journal for more information.
Uh, oh no.
There's an Everdune's Journal!
Okay, after watching Sirus and Akanar, I see they are
handling things very well.
And I think I can put to rest any fears about leaving them
in Channel Wood again.
And for a little longer time.
the tree dweller seems slightly distressed that i am
leaving but are happy that sirius and akinar are staying
behind again i have been gone for over three days and i've
been to many different places i had to tell sirius and
akinar that pran's oh oh about pran's death today and they
were visibly shaken although they only remembered her from
their childhood katherine has suggested that it would be
wise for sirius and akinar to leave a while and i have to
agree they will be returning with me when i leave again
giggle bites of welcome to membership thank you this is
serious it's serious oh my gosh i have told my sons that
they will be returning with me in in two days they spent the
entire night telling me of an adventure they experienced in
my absence and it was rather remarkable it seems they
constructed a boat with the creatures and traveled some ways
out into the surrounding waters.
I enjoy hearing them talk excitedly of their adventures.
Is that the boat that's sunk then?
And I'm reminded of my own adventures as a child.
I finally understand why the tree dwellers have been giving
me their many inks and insisting I write with them.
Looking through some of my past entries I see now that the
inks have changed from the black I thought they were to
various different colors.
I have shown some of the creatures my and they laughed and
howled.
I did not know they had such a sense of humor.
Even now, as I look back, oh, look through this very
colorful journal, I cannot help but laugh myself.
Yeah, get pranked, Bozo.
We will be returning tomorrow, so my sons are with the
creatures for the last night here.
They have told me that they would like to come to
Channelwood again and also asked if they can visit some
other ages alone.
Though I will have to think over their request.
I believe they have proven to me that I'm like using every
single brain cell to read these, you guys.
That they are trustworthy and responsible.
Catherine will also have to help me decide whether they are
ready for travel alone.
For now, I must give my farewells to the creatures for I do
not know how long it will be until I visit this age again.
Oh!
Holy cow!
Osmoian, ages of reference joke about Cyan's earlier games,
Cosmic Osmo.
Oh, neat.
Holy.
That was this one, right?
Yeah.
I should call her.
I'm thinking the same thing.
Back in the day, you had to read entire in-game novels for
the possibility of a hint about what to do next.
I know!
Wait a second!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
These are important.
Who let the author cook?
I'm playing piano!
Oh my gosh.
I doubt.
Okay.
They're so burnt.
Look at all of them.
It kind of looks like...
No, no, Graham.
What is this?
Why are there so many?
Wait, why are there...
Okay.
Only 300 codes that we have to...
Which one was that?
This one?
Okay, it's this one on the floor, right?
Okay, this one's not so long.
Yes, it is, but...
God!
Just making sure I got all of them.
I think it's like all the thicker books.
What's this one supposed to be?
Oh, wait.
Oh, stop, stop, stop.
guy okay this book needs an audio version this is the
perfect time you know how in metal gear solid v how you can
listen to the audio you can listen to the tapes while you
walk around usually i don't want to do that but this would
be the perfect time to to do have that feature how
much of this do you
I mean probably an algorithm to those 300 codes that will
let you create them all The game is old They don't have the
technology They do They have literal spaceships What are you
talking about
Minstogenshi self It would be Much bigger
It would be Much bigger.
Okay, I'm going to take a break from reading because I will
go bonkers.
I need to see the sunlight.
And we're going to go to the dentist.
And we are going to try.
Uh...
Wait, I'm already on October.
I'm a genius.
October 11th.
Oh.
1984.
Okay.
I don't know why it stops the audio.
I love these games.
Like these in school.
Yeah!
And then 10.04 a.m.
Okay.
This was the sunken ship.
Let's see what we got.
Wait, why is it like...
Oh, the light is still on.
That's why.
I'm stupid.
Okay.
I guess I can't shut the door.
Alright!
I'm gonna take a picture of this with my phone.
Oh, why do I have flash on?
Turn off?
Turn off flash?
Off flash.
Okay.
Okie dokie!
Let's do January...
17th?
12.07.
Oh, whoops.
07 at 5.46 a.m.
I take a picture.
Alright, and let's do November 23rd.
9,791.
1,791 at 6...
Oh, no, no, I had it.
Okay, at 6, 57 p.m.
Okay, what do we got?
Whoa, that one's kind of freaky looking.
It looks like a deer or something.
All right.
Very good.
Yeah, not a minute, Before or later, we are extremely
punctual.
Alright, I think that's all we can do here for now.
And I did want to...
Not you.
Go here.
Oh, I think I wasn't.
There we go.
Okay.
There were the vaults, you know.
Let's see.
She has not managed to find a world book yet.
No.
I just started the game!
Am I supposed to find it immediately?
59 volts.
I imagine that's the power to this.
Maybe it's just the power.
Oh no, to the spaceship, right?
Hmm.
I went over.
We were so close.
We were so close to greatness.
Why is it only going to one side, though?
Wait a second.
Never anticipated players would be able to take
high-resolution pictures.
Yeah.
I blew the breaker.
Wait, how do I re- Wait, do you think I have to...
Oh my gosh, that's annoying.
Wait, do I have to go, like, flip the switch again here?
Like that?
Can I even get in here?
Okay, not yet.
Oops.
No!
Okay, hold on.
Let's, uh, before we do that, though, I'm going to number
each and every one of these so that we don't just trial and
error.
So, we have 10, 7, 8,
16, Five.
That's the ones on the left.
All right.
Then we have one.
Two.
Twenty-two.
Nineteen.
And nine.
Okay, awesome.
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh, wrong way?
There we go.
Where is the... Oh, wait, I wonder if it's that bad boy
right there.
Maybe.
I don't know what this means, but it's my brain blast.
It's when I'm super smart.
Okay.
Okay, dokey.
What equals 59?
Time for a calculator.
Calculator.
I'm going to, okay, I'm going to brute force this.
I'm going to start with 22, 19.
Oops, oops, oops, oops.
What?
Uh, 9?
Oh, okay, 22, 19, 9, and 1.
Okay, okay, I got this.
22, 19.
Wait!
Why?
Hmm.
Is there another breaker?
There's two breakers, I think.
Me think.
That's stupid.
Whoops, wrong way.
Trying to see what like the...
It goes to here.
It doesn't go anywhere else.
The wire.
Follow the lines.
It's right here.
Oh!
No!
Oh, asshole!
How am I supposed to get over there?
Uh...
Dang it.
It's bitter.
Oh my gosh, I could have solved it if I was just smart!
How do...
This is one of the advantages of the 3D version.
You can actually walk up to it.
Right!
Does anyone know you can spoil this?
We're only trying to get to a place, so I don't mind.
Is it something that I can reach at the moment, or do I have
to wait?
Click next to the door.
Whoa!
Whoa.
Okay.
I did see this building.
I did not see how we would be able to get to it.
So I just accidentally got to it.
I'm still not sure how.
Okay, like that, I suppose.
Yeah, I just click towards it.
Okay, so here?
Aha!
Thank you!
All right.
Thank you very much, team.
This is why we're a team.
This is why we're a team, everybody.
Okay, what was it?
22, 19, 9.
Oh, it's 59 volts!
I thought it was 51.
Wait, I can do this, I can do this.
8, 9.
Okay.
I almost...
I almost, I almost, I almost really...
ruined it this is the piano wait how's
the audio by the way you can tell me if it's too low or not
would you believe me if i told you guys i used to do like
piano recitals and stuff
now i'm cracked oh yeah baby oh yeah
Really good.
I
have vivid core memory of my parents drawing directly on the
computer monitor screens for one of these puzzles!
No way!
Well, I have to.
What is this here now?
Okay.
Tip for the wonderful piano concert.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh.
You can slide those.
Oh, I can.
Reboot!
Oh.
I do remember the piano book.
Yes, indeed.
I do.
I don't remember which one it was.
Might have been this one.
There's so much text.
Oh.
I take a photo?
Alright, let's go back.
I love modern technology!
Oops.
I did flip the other switch for that cabin, right?
All right, one.
Four.
Oh, sorry, that's not how you count.
I didn't, okay, I'll go back, one.
Maybe I have to do it on the other, on here.
Well, how would I?
Wait, but, but.
What was it?
Pitch perfect!
Ah!
What was it?
Wait, oh.
Oh.
Nothing happened.
That was definitely it though, no?
Oh, what?
Oh!
I got the wrong thing!
Baa!
Oh!
There we go.
Whoa!
Watch out, buddy!
Oh my gosh!
Whoa.
Is this what it used to look like?
Who's driving this thing?
The trees.
Ooh, my eyes.
A bit right.
McDonald's Wi-Fi.
How
do I go home?
Oh, shoot.
Ugh.
It's in my eardrums.
What does that do?
There was so much I...
I didn't...
Whoa!
Whoa.
There was so much I haven't done yet.
So much to live for.
Can I move this?
I guess that's light.
I think maybe these are similar to the things over in the
other world.
So let's press all of these.
You know, kind of like the switches that I needed to pull
down.
Maybe it's similar.
puzzles.
Oh.
Well, this is where I was.
Wind.
I'm trying to, like, look through this, but I guess not.
Oh!
Uh.
Guys, I'm scared.
Where am I?
That's a microphone.
Wait.
Please.
Okay, never mind.
I thought I could click these.
Oh.
What a terrible sound.
Hold on.
Outer Wilds?
We're getting a sound?
Maybe?
Uh-huh.
I can't tell if it's just looping or not, you know?
Hmm.
So far, I have no clue.
So far, um, no idea.
Hmm.
Where haven't I been?
This area is so confusing.
I fear I will be...
Um, really lost.
Oh, wait, there's a note here.
Oh, I got a red page!
Wait, where do I...
How do I...
How do I bring it to my red page?
Wait, I got a red page.
Can't remember if you have to manually save.
I think you do.
You should save, huh?
Oh, it does have an auto-save.
But I'll save too.
Sounds...
Okay, resume.
Just hold on to it for now!
Okay.
What if I need to grab something else?
Sounds...
I don't know where to go.
How long until I can go home?
Kuchida no, no, no, no.
I'm stuck.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, I keep going to the same place.
Sorry.
Can I go home?
I don't know what's going on here yet.
Oh, there's also a...
There was a mic here too though.
Oh.
do you speak whale do you speak whale oh the trees water oh
wait what about my red page it's a purple page currently
it's gone it went back to the other spot I see why do we
have microphones by the onsen
This is so mysterious.
Who built all this?
I guess we'll just have to remember...
Oh, whoops, wrong way.
Remember where the other one was.
Okay, okay, okay.
I think I understand.
Okay.
that order before maybe we have to put the sounds oh my gosh
okay I think
it might have been the order we learned over here so clock
equals
Clock sounds And like, yeah
How do you describe this?
The book in the library talks more about the ages Mateus
spent quite a bit of time Building each of them Usually
several months or more for each one With help typically Oh
The clocky Clocky with occasional
rings.
You hear that?
Blah?
Okay.
What else?
The colorful rot?
Wait, what does this one look like, though?
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
What is this thing called?
I literally had to save...
Oh my gosh.
What is this thing called again?
I literally said it because... Oh, the Yes, the obelisk,
thank you.
Obelisk equals flute.
Oh, good.
Okay, it did go back to your life.
When Nimmy and Phoebe and I all did the escape room
together,
they were like, do you know what this shape is?
And it was an obelisk.
It's an obelisk!
And they were like, how do you know that?
And I was like, didn't every kid have like a...
Like a...
An Egypt phase?
Okay, wind.
Okay, these are...
Okay, wind equals wind.
Easy peasy.
No.
We need to go this way.
Oh my gosh.
It's so hard to click!
please let me go this way is it this way is it this way no
this goes back to the fluids there was like an underground
passage this is the clocks this is the fire but what's the
symbol okay it's the crack in the ground the lightning crack
equals fire sounds.
I think it can use keyboard to walk?
Why should I?
No, it doesn't seem like it.
Point only.
And then there was this one over here.
This is probably water.
Yep.
I guess I really don't need to write these down.
But that's fine.
That's fine.
Water.
equals water sounds.
Still have the book of my dead for my childhood Egypt phase.
I think every kid went through an Egypt phase.
Especially if you were like a millennial kid.
Because you watched, I know you watched the mummy and you
were like, I'm gonna become an archaeologist now.
It's literally just what happens.
Is it this way?
Oh, I can just go in here.
I'm silly.
I forgot.
Guilty as charged.
I know, I know.
You are not alone.
Okay, here we go.
I feel like we'll have to come back here, though, for...
Am I supposed to look at it?
Let's see.
Or is this the view from it?
I think this is the view from it.
Alright.
It's water.
Crack.
Clock.
Obelisk.
Wind.
Okay.
Get me out of here.
We're braining.
We're braining right now.
Do you guys think I'm right?
I don't know.
It seems like you're cooking.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, so water.
sound.
Train sound.
Oh, water!
Wait.
Water sound.
Maybe that.
I just have to be on it.
Okay, it's the very last one.
Okay, crack is a fire sound.
Okay.
This one.
Clock is clocky sound.
Obelisk is flutey sound.
Wind is...
Windy sound.
This one?
Every kid has an ancient Egypt phase, but nobody leaves
their ancient Rome phase!
Ha ha ha!
Did I do it wrong?
If
something happens, you've missed something.
That was the order on that thing.
Maybe I guess that's not the order.
18 months!
Thank you, Deacross!
Thank you!
I missed something.
Long hair Minto is my Roman Empire.
Is it now?
Something with the cameras, I'm guessing.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Hint!
Gentler with the camera.
Okay.
We'll go back to the camera.
I can't remember how to get there.
I guess we just go to the wind and we go into the passage.
I remember how to get there.
I was such a liar.
Why did I say that?
I'm seeing if there's anything that I should be aiming at.
Okay.
The bottom button will light up, will it?
Oh, thank you for that hint.
Okay, that makes things so much easier.
Brain cell boosting glasses are a good move.
I want to see if it, like, flashes really quick.
It does not.
Just...
Ugh.
I want to aim it at the right sound.
Yeah, but it all sounds the same.
Like, I feel like it's on a loop.
Like, I feel like...
Let's hold on.
Be.
Look for satellite dishes.
Is that what it is?
Because I did see one in here.
here.
This guy.
Maybe that?
Yeah, I did press the buttons off the side.
I did press those.
Try the clock first.
Is that one easier?
Oh!
Maybe I didn't press the water one.
Okay, okay, okay.
I don't think I pressed the water one.
Awesome.
Because I was like, it really doesn't change at all, you
guys.
Okay.
Back to the water, all the way to the front.
Wrong.
This way.
Wait, I did, though.
It didn't show up at all, though.
The clock one showed up, like, immediately.
Okay.
Whoops.
Water is hard to find.
We'll try the other ones first then.
Okay.
This is like...
Perfect quality.
This is it.
55.6, baby.
Okay.
This is the...
Uh...
This one makes the fire sounds.
Is that it right there?
No.
Does the E light up when perfect?
I don't think so.
I feel like this has to be perfect though though.
Oh, that's the clock again.
Then it would be over here.
There we go.
I know my
direction.
Extreme precision.
I can't tell.
I can't tell!
I feel like I'm always hearing static.
Blink equals close, stop blink equals perfect.
Like this blink right here.
This is so nostalgic!
Hopefully you'll beat it because I never could as a kid.
Yeah, me too.
I'll do my best.
We got it.
Awesome.
Oh my gosh, that is so useful.
Thank you.
so then okay that one's not blinking this one is the flute
noise it should be extremely easy to hear
this should be in here
this is like a nice little visual clue if you know what it
means
okay okay the wind which one oh the wind was the tunnel
So...
Wind tunnel!
Ah, okay.
Nice!
Okay.
Water.
Would be...
Where's the fire?
There.
So it would be this way.
Right?
Unless it's over more?
Ah!
Oh my gosh, I finally found it.
Hi!
Is that it?
Oh, it's telling me the order!
Wait, hold on.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
One more time.
Flute.
Oblisk.
Water.
Wind.
Fire.
Uh, uh, obelisk.
One more time.
Water.
Fire.
Clock.
Okay, we got it.
Do you think I need to remember these numbers?
Probably not, right?
Mayhaps.
I hope not.
I don't think they would be that.
That's...
It's just for that puzzle, right?
It's not for...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's not for any other puzzle, right?
Okay, here we go.
All right, first is flute.
Okay, water.
Oh, here we go.
Fire.
Clock.
I mean, don't play an avatar over here.
I know, I feel like...
Oh my god, I did
it.
A submarine?
Here comes the fun part, lie.
Alright, don't lie.
No.
Wait, no way there's a water level in this game.
What am I doing in here?
Is Iron Lung real?
Is the Iron Lung movie out yet?
This part is all audio key.
What the hell does that mean?
What the hell does that
mean?
Welcome to Rapture.
I'm guessing all of these...
I'm guessing the pink is like the correct sound.
Right.
Okay.
Each sound has a specific meaning.
There are four possible sounds after every stop.
You came from the south heading north.
Yeah, I do remember that.
Wait,
we haven't even gone back to North, have we?
I was trying to find North again.
I hope you took notes from earlier in the game.
I have notes?
um everything was the same sound literally every single one
just kidding
so if i go back i guess at home
i was responding to a text from someone Almost put a green
heart at the end.
Would have been very confusing in that combo.
That's funny.
Thank you, Darko!
Okay.
Can I get out of here?
I didn't read about this world.
This is my home now.
Okay.
We're going back.
Um...
Sweet land, sweet land.
Okay, hold on.
I still haven't even tried to see if I can go home or not.
Oh.
Definitely not.
Wait.
The door doesn't even open up anymore.
I have a pain.
Um...
Oh my god, sad chaps!
Thank you so much for the Hakasupa!
Merry Crembus, boss!
Thank you!
Merry Crembus!
Oh...
Do I have to do this?
Oh, I have to do the puzzle again, too.
You're stuck here until you solve the maze runner.
Alright.
Will you guys assist me?
Will you guys help me out since...
I'm okay with backseating here.
We got you?
Okay, give me one second.
I'm gonna go grab some water.
While this does its thing, I'll be right back.
Alright, I grabbed some water and two slice of pizza
because...
I didn't have time to eat dinner.
So I apologize.
All right, guys, let's lock in.
Let's lock in.
I'm hoping that eating will wake me up, too, because I've
been falling asleep.
What you got on your pizza?
I've got tomato, spinach, green pepper.
Sorry, you can hear how hard it is.
It's leftovers.
Uh, yeah.
Okay.
Veggie pizza.
Okay, forward.
Love me some spinch.
Me too.
Okay.
We are from south headed north.
I'm going to write that down because I will forget.
From south.
headed north.
rotate west?
I was gonna ask, is there like a certain sound I should be
looking out for?
Can you imagine being the person who actually lived on this
island?
Can you imagine how annoying locking up for the night?
Right!
Only way out is through!
Let's go!
There are four possible noises.
What else are the four?
So you guys are saying, okay, Dink sound equals north.
Brrr sound is west.
So we're going west.
Brrr is west.
Brrr.
Whoa.
Now.
Oh, north.
Now what have I need to go northwest will it be like pink
you know it will okay at least two sounds at once okay
northwest would be think okay okay i'm not gonna remember
how to get home wait what the hell was that Bang?
Zang?
East.
Okay, thank you guys.
How the hell are you supposed to annoy the police?
Don't.
Weeks of fun!
Okay, east?
South!
Wait, eat pizza.
Let's go!
Okay, okay.
This isn't so bad.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you so much.
I don't tell you which direction you need to go in the first
two nodes.
I have only one way forward, so they...
So...
They teach you north and west, and then the rest is logic.
This is... Okay.
That was south, right?
Whoa!
Wee!
That
was West.
Right?
Right.
I wonder where we're going.
How do we do it?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hands up!
Put your hands in the air!
They're off the lap bar!
Uh.
Was that south?
Or not south.
Wait.
Where are we facing south?
Oh.
It's too south.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I need to write these down.
Southwest.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oops, wrong way.
I'm gonna listen again.
Oh, okay, I see it.
I hear it.
Alright, alright, alright.
Why do you build it like this, though?
West.
Yes.
Let's go.
As a joke.
Is that Northwest?
I think so.
I don't remember what North sounds like anymore.
My man went crazy with it.
Northeast?
I went the wrong way.
But I'm committed.
I went the wrong way, but I'm committed.
There we go.
Wins the drop!
Just north.
Wrong way.
Good old north.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, we're going a little sideways.
Whoa, whoa, we're turning.
Whoa, which way are we facing?
Whoa, whoa.
How long is this?
What sound was that?
I don't remember.
Huh?
Too long.
Oh, it's cowbell.
Oh, so it's southeast.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to press that.
There we go.
Okay, this should be the last one.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
That's new, that's new.
That's new!
New, new, new, new, new, new, new!
Did I make it?
Ooh!
Mist.
The game's puzzles are truly mystifying.
Oh.
I wish all my...
I wish all my books had MP4s.
Are we going home?
Oh!
He returned.
He wouldn't return.
This age is a rescue.
me
my brother I beg you
to be complete VTuber?
you say are you a VTuber?
always blue pages you listen to him not listen to my brother
say don't listen to him or listen to him Oh, just kidding.
He says don't listen to me.
Don't bring the red ones.
Prisons?
I will have my retribution.
Pages!
The pages!
Well that made a whole lot of...
That was a whole lot of A whole lot of nonsense, huh, guys?
Don't listen to my brother.
Only bring blue pages.
I've been wrongly imprisoned, basically.
Okay, okay.
Thank you for the TL notes.
No, thank you for the...
Wait, but we have a red page we can go grab.
Wait, would I have to do all that, though, to get back?
Wait, where's my ship?
Oh, it's here, yeah.
I would have to do everything again.
And by everything, I mean the...
The subway.
Are there multiple endings to this game?
There are!
No, four endings!
Three!
Three, four endings?
Wow.
Including the secret one.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I didn't know Mist was such like a...
Why?
I feel like there...
Why has there never been like a TV show based on this?
Because people are lame.
Why?
Several books and sequels instead.
Oh wait, we gotta get this too.
Uh, this rotation.
Let's go, let's go figure that out because I forgot to do it
before.
If it's, if it's even a thing, you know.
Let's go see.
Uh, you.
Oh my god.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
That's it, right?
I'm so sorry!
Alright, let's go tower rotate.
Awesome.
is actually really dark and messed up.
Is there cannibalism?
Is there...
Let's see.
Big tree.
724.
Wait!
That must be the code for the safe in there.
That's a question I cannot answer in good faith.
Yeah, yeah.
Hmm, your silence tells me everything.
Which brother eats which?
Yeah, I don't know.
I keep playing games with cannibalism.
It's like my thing now.
I'm like the cannibal YouTuber.
It's answered in game four.
I have to play four games to get to the cannibalism.
That should be a main attraction.
If you are what you eat, then the only way to be a person is
to eat a person.
Alright, what was it?
724.
Where are these?
A match.
I'm gonna burn it all to...
I'm gonna burn it all to hell.
Oh, I gotta light this baby.
Uh...
What do you want me to do with it?
Do I have to use the thing here?
Ah, okay.
Does that do it?
Mitt, you know how matches work?
I don't...
I didn't think about it, okay?
That seems kind of strong.
I'm gonna save fire.
Before we continue.
There we go.
All right.
This isn't moving, though, up here.
So maybe...
Should I shut the door?
Alright.
Huh.
I want to go to the clock.
All things are happening.
Looks like there's an eyeball in there looking at me.
Freaky.
Oh, there's autosave.
It's still there.
In case you were wondering.
In case you were like, um.
Because I also was curious.
More.
There's also a face in the safe.
Now when I don't see it.
Whoa!
Um...
Oh!
Something exploded!
What explode?
What's exploding?
Go to the tree.
How do I get the tree?
Uh, uh, behind the cabin.
It's so difficult getting to the tree.
Oh my god.
Wait, uh, Buck.
Oh, there we are.
I didn't even know this existed.
Okay.
I feel like we should be able to go up higher, no?
God,
there's so many tiny things you can miss.
Oh, this is what I saw from the deck.
Because I was like, I definitely...
I was like, I...
This is a timing puzzle.
Oh my god.
Oh,
I see, I see it, okay, but...
Do I need to press it?
We're gathered here today to remember Mintventum, who died
again tragically in a steam boiler explosion.
I was wicked crazy and cynical.
One.
Oh my gosh, if I could get over.
There we go.
Wait, where's the door?
It's rotating.
Look up?
Um, I don't think that's possible.
How do I look up?
It must be way gone then.
Gamers don't look up.
Miss...
Miss Man, don't look up.
Get closer and click on the top of the screen.
What do you think I did?
Oh!
There it is.
Is it still going up?
Did it stop?
Or...
Do I have to just like, sit in... Do I have to...
Okay, so let's turn this off, then.
Oh.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, I think that was the sound of it.
Oh my gosh, it's...
There it comes.
Ah!
That's so fun.
You think it'll go back up, though?
Probably not, right?
Oh,
I need to go down!
Oh!
I thought I was going to the top of the tree!
Tree!
Tree world!
Whoa, whoa!
We're gonna be a little monkey!
Let's go!
This
is the channel wood book.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Can I go in?
Let's go.
Yeah!
Whoa.
Oh boy.
I'm messing with the local ecosystem.
I'm disrupting the flow.
I'm pulling levers and pressing buttons!
The toilet?
I think I need power.
Welcome to the bayou.
What we got going on up here?
Interesting.
Will we find my Oshi Frog Bird?
That guy wouldn't dare step in a...
In such a disgusting place.
Wait.
Okay, that way.
I thought the shadow, it looked like it was like building up
water.
How do I distribute the water to here?
I think that's what I need to do.
No, or...
Let's try over here.
What's this one?
No.
This is probably the friendliest zone.
Is it?
I'm getting freaked out by the frog sounds.
Hmm.
The easiest?
Don't say that.
Because when I can't figure it out, I'll feel really stupid.
Let's see.
I want to try to get over there.
This area.
Yeah.
Oh, it's locked.
I hear you running.
I hear you working.
You're literally...
Come on.
Work.
You have generator sound now.
Maybe I'll...
Wait.
I can't even tell where I'm at.
That's, I think, the most confusing part about this place
for me.
me is it looks everywhere looks so similar so i'm gonna get
lost like how i feel yeah this guy's not making any noise
where was the other one
uh let's go back this way what's over here a tree all right
all right all right all right
This one is way easier in the 3D versions.
I can imagine.
I'm like lost as hell right now.
I'm not gonna be that... I'm not gonna lie.
There's two of these though!
No!
Am I dumb?
Was it just the one this whole time?
Oh, it was just the one this whole time.
Okay, okay, alright.
We gotta figure out how to get the water over here.
I keep getting turned around though.
Where am I?
Follow the sound of the water and you'll be fine.
Okay.
So now we're making it go this way, I'm assuming.
Let me make it go this way?
And
then...
Ah!
I did it!
I didn't do it.
Ah!
Maybe I hold it?
Do I shut the... this?
Oh!
Shit!
We made it.
I'm in someone's home, maybe.
Oh my god.
I can't tell where I am at all.
Okay.
Where did I come from?
Oh god.
Point and click adventure.
I wonder if kids who grew up playing puzzle games got an
unrealistic...
Unrealistic expectation of having to solve puzzles all day
as an adult.
I mean, weren't you a kid once?
This is someone's home!
Let's go this way.
Someone else is home!
It's their home!
Wow, this person loved pottery!
They loved pottery.
Like, I'm pottery's biggest fan.
No other bigger fan of pottery than I.
I'm the pottery creature.
What's this?
What the hell did that just do?
Oh, I think it opened the door?
Over there?
Pottery creature.
Okay, nice.
Open the door, I think, for the...
um spiral staircase so let's go back to pottery this way
i'm looking for pages even too i gotta find me a blue page
for my buddy eustace i don't remember his name i don't
remember his name sorry
uh this way
were you the ghost in ghost uh no wait what is this oh
oh because of the pottery wait do i get to have like a super
sensual moment then with i'm patrick suazy
is it me or did she close it again i don't what the door i
don't know it's so hard to see I don't even know where that
was, that little switch.
It's really hard to see.
You guys see as well as I do, so...
If I can't tell, if you can't tell, I can't tell.
I'm Patrick Swayze.
I mean, Patrick Swayze is a ghost now.
Not every dead person turns into a ghost.
I don't think that guy's a ghost at all.
I don't know.
I don't know him.
I lost the lever.
Didn't he die?
I thought so.
I'm so lost.
Wait.
Pottery.
From pottery.
Here.
I can't tell.
I don't think I'm Patrick Swayze.
What?
I only know him from Ghost.
What else has he done?
What else has Patrick Swayze done?
That I could maybe steal for my resume.
Say that it was me.
If I'm Patrick Swayze.
Roadhouse.
Oh, dirty dancing!
We're dirty dancing!
Dirty dancing!
We're dirty, and we're dancing, we're Dirty dancing, and
that's Dirty Dan, and I'm Dirty dancing with Dirty Dan, and
we're Dirty dancing, that's the plan, and we're Dirty
dancing till we can't, we're Dirty dancing.
I opened the door.
So that elevator there, where does it lead to?
It's like right next door.
I can't believe you memorized the lyrics.
It's like I'm the biggest fan of that song.
So one of the first games I ever played on PC.
I'm not counting Putt Putt goes to the moon.
Super excited to see you playing this.
Thank you, Kane!
Thank you!
I guess this one doesn't matter, huh?
Wait, if I do that...
you don't even like see it leaking okay all right and then
here like that okay now this i just want to see what the
elevator does
i feel oh it goes up here i thought it was okay i i don't I
don't know why I was like, they only go up and down.
I didn't realize there was like so many layers.
I guess they did say that in the book, huh?
Oh.
Oh!
Uh, we're just gonna forget that happened?
What the?
Oh!
Whatever he got paid, it wasn't enough.
Oh my gosh, it's a trap!
I like how we just leave and are like, okay!
Wait.
Wait, there was this...
Okay, this is where I came from, okay.
Just trying to get my bearings, you know?
So he was just speaking the creature language, the
tree-dweller language.
Okay, let's go this way.
What's in here?
Oh, a thing.
Oh, blue bear.
Blue page, blue page!
Zanzibar.
Now that's Patrick Swayze.
What did that mouth do?
Oh!
pushed the right button my brother what a very interesting
device you have here i'm not erasing anything important in
mind remember he is preparing take only one page my dear
brother oh my gosh wait it's liquid What used to...
Brother, I hope I'm not writing over anything important.
Brother?
Interesting.
Naruhodo.
Naruhodo took.
The music in there is so whimsical.
Wait, go back.
Oh, I thought there was a door here.
Um...
Was there anything else I missed?
Oh, this way.
Whoa, fancy room!
Whoa!
Oh, this must be the brother's room.
This is the brother.
Open your drawers.
A knife.
Missed.
Switches on the island.
Mmm.
Vault access, you say?
I'm taking a picture of this.
Alright.
Took a picture of that?
Very good.
What's over here?
A sink.
And his toothbrush?
He's so sophisticated.
He's so like, I don't participate in your...
Monkey business.
That's what he says.
The red page.
I think I'm about...
Blue Page guy.
I think I'm Team Blue Page.
Oh, no running water.
You're...
I don't have to go all the way down.
I think this is cheese?
I couldn't even tell.
I think you're right.
You don't?
It's fine.
Okay, thank goodness.
Thank you.
I do kind of want to see the other side.
But at the same time, I'm like, I'd have to...
Wait, it wouldn't let me grab anything, though.
But I would have to come back to all these worlds.
That's the only thing stopping me.
You don't want the page, do you?
Is that what you desire?
Definitely the page and not my hand.
yeah when they say aged cheese whose room is this oh this
must be Eustace's room blue man yeah yeah because he has the
thing oh
oh okay it's just jail
it's only one world that is annoying to redo for the second
page I haven't been here long so I don't if you've been
there i don't know i've been to is it the one with the
subway because if so yes
am i missing something i mean yes but am i like am i not
seeing something is what i mean because i can't go anywhere
else you got everything here wait how do i leave then How do
I get home?
There's just the way home.
Which
is...
Oh, the first...
Oh, sorry, I'm still like...
Oh, wait, wrong way.
I'm still learning the games, like, what it wants me to do a
little bit, still.
I guess there's no book?
Yeah, that's what I was looking for, was, like, a book or
something.
Hmm.
How do I get downstairs from here?
Oh, wait.
I can take the...
I'm stupid.
I can take the stairs.
You're doing great.
Aw, thanks, guys.
I'm having fun.
I was worried that I would be like, oh, my gosh, I'm way too
stupid for this game.
But only so far, I'm just a little bit stupid for it.
Where is the elevator?
How do I get home, everybody?
I'm doing really good.
Thank you!
You're one of the most big, big brain gamers I've seen.
Wow!
I don't know how to get home, though.
Elevator is ground level.
Is this not the ground level?
Is there more ground?
Is there under sea level?
Ground.
Wait, it wasn't in the ground.
Wait, oh.
It's not this one.
This one led upstairs.
Maybe it's over here.
Oh, I think it's this one then.
Okay, we gotta direct the water over here.
I was wondering what that was for.
I didn't...
I knew how we got down here and yeah, I still was like...
I don't know.
This one?
Wait, I have to be looking at it.
This way.
No, no, please!
Please let me click you!
Wait, uh...
Wait, I'm lost.
This, this way.
Okay.
This way!
I did it wrong.
Oh, that's why.
My bad.
There we go.
Oh!
Neat!
How did I get over here?
wait how do i get home though the water is broke oh i have
to cry
oh my god oh my god we gotta go all the way back oh weeks of
fun weeks of fun
okay from here wait from here Where am I?
I'm lost.
We go to this way now.
I don't hear the water though.
Where's the water?
Oh, I think the water is here.
Okay.
Wait, uh...
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, yes.
Yes?
Okay, back around!
Oh my gosh.
What if you have to pee?
I guess you just pee in the water, huh?
But like, what if you really have to go?
You're like, I just want the comfort of my own.
I want the comfort of my own bathroom.
Always finding ways to crank it in games.
Oh man, that one wasn't so bad though.
It's just disorienting.
That's my biggest...
My biggest enemy.
Oh, there's the boy!
There!
Yeah, the 3D remake I can imagine makes us so much easier.
But it feels like classic doing it like this, you know?
Ah, yeah.
Wait, what time is my meeting tonight?
Sorry, I'm meeting with the other Den Setsu girls for
something.
Let me, before we watch it, let me make sure.
Oops.
Because otherwise, we can just finish the game tomorrow.
A VTuber playing Myst!
Hello, hello!
Okay, yeah, after this, I think I might...
I had a meeting earlier, literally right before stream with
Steiner.
like a weekly kind of catch-up meeting with my manager and
then tonight, me and the Den Setu girls are meeting to
discuss some cool stuff, so you've made great progress for
one night if you've got to stop.
Yeah, unfortunately, we're meeting in about an hour and I
kind of want to eat before then.
I think this is a good stopping point.
If you guys say we're 50% through the game, we can finish it
tomorrow.
Yeah, I'm good.
Two more pages, I got you.
Bring more.
You need more.
Well, I ask of you.
Okay.
More.
It's so long since my brother...
Serious wrongfully amazes into me within this walk.
Oh, stupid schemes.
They were like Mac filters.
Breathe, which is endless.
What's endless?
It should be perfectly obvious to you.
He's done evil and he has destroyed all before.
Do not bring the red pages to him.
Please.
Not let him trip you.
You believe me?
Please say, tell me.
Huh?
He seriously murdered my father!
He murdered your dad!
He murdered their dad!
Okay, okay, this guy's yapping up a storm.
Listen, you must obey.
Oh, I don't like the word obey though.
Ages are my only hope.
You must help me.
Help me.
He just keeps saying the same thing over and over again.
What was that about their father?
The brother murdered their father?
Is that what he said?
So this guy?
He murdered their father?
Allegedly.
How might Detective Brett Alegon handle this situation?
It's so good seeing you play this.
You can play through all six games.
Well, I did not intend on that.
In fact, I only learned that there were more than one today.
Today I learned there was more than one missed game.
But, uh...
We'll see.
I think we made good progress today, though.
We still have stuff about these constellations.
We still have all of these little critters.
We still have the pipes over there.
I think probably I'll start the next stream with getting the
red pages and then continuing from there.
Actually, I don't even know where to go from here.
We did the spaceship.
I'll figure it out, I suppose.
Riven is hard, but incredible.
That's the sequel to this one.
Oh, yeah, we got the Metal Gears.
That's right.
Imagine being in prison, pleading for help, and the person
on the other side rolls her eyes and says, Yep, yep, yep.
Happy one year anniversary of Endothuse, right?
Yeah!
Was going through my photos and remembering what a great
time it was.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Ribbon, the sequel to Mist.
Oh, okay, okay.
Tell the denser to girlies, you said hi.
I will.
Dorgo, thank you so much for the pink!
It was fun.
Watch your mega mind minke gameplay.
You did great.
Looking forward to next time.
Have fun discussing cool stuff in your meeting.
But please make sure to sleep tonight too.
Yes, I will sleep tonight.
I will.
Ribbon's amazing.
Thank you, RoboCorps!
Thank you for helping too.
We'll see if I...
You know, I don't see why I wouldn't want to play it, but...
I would look into it.
But yeah!
Let me save before we do anything.
Save...
Blue Pages...
Team.
Team Blue Pages.
Yay!
Thank you, everybody!
So, so much!
exactly at like three hours.
Wowie.
Thank you, everyone!
I had so much fun being a big brain.
Now I can take off my smart glasses and return to being an
idiot.
You should check out Pissed.
It's an awful parody.
Oh, God.
I'm dumb again!
Thanks, everyone!
Have a good day, have a good night, and I will see you when
I see you.
Next time, eat the dashai.
Bye-bye.
I'm back to being a bimbo.
I'm just a bimbo.
I got nothing on in my brain.
Nothing going on up there.
I'm just thinking about...
What...
Boys?
Okay, bye!